so today i thought i would do a bit of
video just telling you a bit more about
me and why we did sidetrack and to you
know answer some of those questions that
i get quite often on the channel no oh
no wait a second no no no no that's
boring no one wants to listen to that
i challenge you to pick five characters
you would want to see in the new
stargate series that's what the people
want jay that's what they want well
okay that's a
bit cheeky is is my subordinate i
invited him to join the channel and this
is how he treats me but
but i okay
five characters that i would love to see
return if stargate returns
okay well let's get into it welcome to
scitrek your sci-fi tv and movie channel
[Music]
okay a little bit on the spot here but
five characters i'd love to see return
in no particular order okay well first
of all i think we have to go with david
blue
um he is 100 a massive stargate fan he
talks about stargate quite a lot he's on
a twitter feed at the moment and he
talks about it quite a lot
but mainly
eli wallace is a character that i think
is fair to say most stargaters would
love to see return
if we get brad wright's version of
stargate and they don't do a reboot or a
hybridization whatever
um of the series
then i think we would get to see
some sort of finale to sgu the fans have
been screaming out for it for years now
and um brad wright and joseph milosev
pretty much said that that's something
they'd like to do if they get the series
so
yeah i could see david blue returning as
ey water wallace mainly because it's
what the fans want
um and i 100 think he would come back
and do it by the way if you do like the
content please don't forget to like and
subscribe and hit the bell notification
you can also consider becoming a member
hit the join button that little bit of
contribution every month really helps us
to create more content next on my list
is an actor that i probably would like
to see the most
he's a character that i always loved he
started off as a recurring character
then actually became a fully fledged
character in his own right in stargate
atlantis of course it's rodney mckay
now i actually follow david hula on
facebook i i message him every so often
i've actually had a few replies even
which um like a little star struck when
david hewlett messages me but he's just
one of those actors that is just likable
in everything he does he's got this
cheeky eyes he's got you know she's been
even when he's been a complete prick you
just adore him
but also i think there are lots of ways
he could be brought into a new series
really really easily stargate atlantis
as far as you know is still on earth i
assume
lots and lots of engineers and people
are tearing the city apart to discover
all of atlantis secrets i should imagine
now rodney's probably in charge of that
mission maybe and so involved in lots of
areas i also think rodney's character
though has a way of getting himself into
trouble sometimes so i could see that
that would be a nice way of creating a
new storyline where rodney discovers
something within the city or something
like that and and gets everybody into
trouble
so yeah i would love to see davis
hewlett return and i think it would be
very very easily in fact the
possibilities are endless of ways you
could bring him back into a new series
next on my list
i'm going to stay with atlantis and go
joel flanagan so yeah i think colonel
john shepard's character in atlantis was
always a lot of fun he could be cheeky i
loved him the way he had banter with
roland and mainly rodney
um but the main reason why i think he
could return is one he adores the
stargate series i mean seriously loves
it he would be back in a heartbeat i
think and there are even rumors that he
apparently tried to buy the rights to
the series a few years ago so that he
could continue the stargate atlanta
storyline so yeah he would 100 return
and he's an actor that i think
he still looks pretty good he hasn't
aged badly he could very most definitely
walk straight into it he goes to all the
conventions he's actually at one of the
stargate conventions this week
um he would 100 come back and he'd be
there in a heartbeat and again i could
see him maybe being commander of the
stargate atlantis project now or
somewhere at the pentagon probably a
general by now but you know there are
lots of giveaways again that you could
write this character in okay so we get
to the two and they're probably
the most likely and the ones the fans
would like to see the most but first of
all i'm gonna say daniel jackson
um i think michael shanks even though he
left the series repeatedly
he could so easily come back um i think
there's lots of story depth um i
actually think stargate really revolves
around daniel jackson's character and
jack o'neill's character so
traditionally they are the the central
point of the whole story
um obviously his knowledge from being an
ancient repeatedly um
there are lots of ways again you could
write his character in he is an actor
that still adores the project he
regularly appears with brad wright on
the companion app
um he talks about stargate a lot his
wife appeared in stargate
i think there are lots of ways you could
write him in and for me
the storyline that the sgc is now
supposed to be known it's it's an open
secret everybody knows about the
stargate on earth
i would make sense to me to have a
civilian commander for the sgc project
and the obvious person to say would be
daniel oh what just so he can die again
yeah all right that's a good point he
dies a lot
bring him back to the first series and
kill him off at the end i don't know
just it would be great to come back i
actually think the most likely
particularly if brad wright gets his way
is samantha carter because he's already
basically hinted that we're going to see
general samantha carter
but i do honestly believe that if amanda
tapping came back she's going to want to
work behind the screen and maybe more
than in front of the screen so i think
if she did come back she would be come
back as a recurring character but i
don't think she'd be central character
to the plot
but i do think she's one of the easiest
characters to come back
um amanda tapping again appears with
brad wright and the companion app all
the time she loves stargaze looks so
that she is now become a very
well-respected director she's become a
very well-respected producer and even
executive producer i actually think they
could bring her back as an executive
producer but get her on screen a fair
bit if brad wright wasn't going to show
run and but they wanted to bring
somebody else back in to show her in the
series i actually don't think bringing
back amanda tapping would be a terrible
idea and in fact i was no mgm have
considered that before in the past so
for me the most likely character i could
see coming back if we get the broadway
version 100 be amanda tapping but i have
to admit out of this list of five people
i've just gone through
the one i want the one i hope they bring
back the most
would be rodney rodney mckay was always
my favorite character from stargate
atlantis and i would adore for him to
return for a new series of star game but
quickly before we go let's have a couple
of honorable mentions
richard dean anderson is obviously the
actor that i think most people
would love to see return for star game
but he is getting on a bit i'm afraid
and he's involved in lots of
environmental projects and things like
this i could see him coming back for one
or two episodes but i could not see him
coming back as a recurring normal
character in any new sgc project
so
sorry to say i just don't think he will
jason manmoha is another actor ronan was
a great character in stargate i always
knew he was going to go on to big things
i remember after stargate when i
realized he was in game of thrones i was
just like yeah that's gonna that's his
thing that's gonna propel him
and then he got the conan movie and you
just knew that this guy was gonna be a
big star and obviously he hasn't
disappointed
there is absolutely no way he'd ever
return to stargate that i can imagine
again
maybe they could talk him to just doing
one episode as a visit but i doubt it
finally a couple of actors i'd just like
to give honorable mentions to that i
would love to see return a duel state
and robert picada again both rob avcardo
appeared as um woolsey in a few episodes
in sg1 and then atlantis you'll stay as
the doctor in atlantis um i just loved
your state i adored her from firefly
she's great and rough robert picada the
doctor
he's just one of those actors that's
he might actually be slightly mental
follow him on facebook some of the
little videos he puts up and things
you've got to wonder what's going on
that man's brain but he's he's a man
that you would just adore to sit down
and have a point with because oh man i
bet you'd have some stores
so yeah i'd love to see those guys
return as well but guys get into the
comments and tell me what you think who
would you love to see return for a new
stargate series and obviously if you are
new to the channel please like subscribe
hit the bell notification it really
helps us out and if you enjoy the
content please consider becoming a fully
fledged side tracker hit the join button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you